I like that feeling when you scratch
your ear feels like the same feeling as
uh well you know no it's dirty hey what
is going on YouTube you know ever since
I decided to open up my channel I
decided to let you guys ask me questions
that I could answer which means you know
I kind of find myself to be a pretty
good listener but recently a subscriber
asked during the Halal of my clan that's
such an interesting question to ask
because in my opinion that's simple as a
pimple my friend that's the dumbest
[ __ ] thing I've ever said you know
making friends is not as hard as you
think it is a mon frere uh-huh that's
French and the reason being is because a
lot of you guys base your friendships on
the wrong types of things so it's that
time again cuz you already know what it
is LGI baby let's get it let's go number
one never base your friendships based on
how somebody else will make you look now
this can work on a couple of levels
listen they're people I understand when
you're young you'll want to look cool I
get it you want to be the girl when
you'll walk down the hallway in high
school all the boys want to smash the
dig pocket oh you want to be the guy
when you're standing out in front of the
school all the girls when they look at
you that vaginas just explode that's a
real thing I'm gonna [ __ ] what you say I
feel like I'm not saying the right
things but listen if you choose your
friends based on their cool factor a
couple of things just might happen you
just might end up very unhappy because
friendships based on appearances never
really work out there is no substance to
that [ __ ] there are no no three I'm
because for one if you base it on
something as shallow as an appearance
and that's all you're really thinking
about what if you don't vibe with them
you know what's going to happen you're
gonna have to change yourself in order
to fit in with that clique you are going
to have to force yourself to be
something that you're not I don't think
you guys realize how difficult it is to
constantly keep up a facade for the rest
of your life it's like if Batman could
never go back to being Bruce Wayne even
if he took off the mask what's up Bruce
where is it what the [ __ ] are you
yelling for
where's
back room oh is that what we're doing
we're just gonna be Batman Forever [ __ ]
and on top of that if you want to be
around somebody because you think they
make you look better guess what they're
really not your friends and you kind of
lose yourself those type of friends are
the ones that will easily get
embarrassed you and will drop your ass
in a second a real friends accept you
for the piece of [ __ ] that you are and
nothing ever changes how many years have
I been on YouTube huh none of my friends
till this day give a [ __ ] about me every
time I come back to Sag town I get
greeted with the same amount of love
shut the [ __ ] up okay Oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
number two the second level of this is
on the flip side is where you're not
wanting to be somebody's friend because
they're not cool enough for you first
off on a more serious don't let me ask
you this [ __ ] who the [ __ ] do you think
you are what makes you think that you're
that special huh put you [ __ ] diamonds
and unicorns out your butt crack [ __ ]
you ain't nobody you're [ __ ] my
little pony dick sucking [ __ ] acting
like your Dookie don't state everybody
Dookie stick it's Dookie it's the only
reason why you don't want to be friends
somebody is because you're afraid how is
going to reflect on your social status
you my friend are a sorry piece of [ __ ]
and you deserve to be alone for the rest
of your life you know what your dumb ass
needs to do you need to watch some
Disney [ __ ] look at that girl
jasmine and then homeless ass dude
Aladdin Princess Jasmine didn't give a
[ __ ] about a social status she fell in
love with a hobo if you want to find
love go outside right now go find a
homeless person on a person rug and rub
a golden teapot that's that's that's
extreme love there's so much
to me
I'll tell you this right now if you're
the type of person to skip on
opportunity to make a connection with
another human being that you buy with
just because of their appearance you are
not going to have friends so here's a
bit of advice when you come down to
earth take your head out your [ __ ]
ass and I know what these type of people
are going to say I have brains [ __ ]
what are you talking about but in all
honesty dude really think about it who
are your real friends who really has
taken the time to get to know you and
who was really there for you when you
needed them the most and most
importantly who was there before and who
will always be there whether you are
rich or you are dirt poor you see for me
I've never really based my friendships
on these superficial things that's why
for me I feel like I am surrounded by
the most positive people I have ever met
in my life because I am proud because I
have met people who I am proud to call
my friends that have built me up to the
man I am today
as you grow older you are going to
realize that you will have to gain the
ability to discern whether people are
just acquaintances or they are your
friends not everybody is your homey
understand recognize and realize who are
the ones that are in your inner circle
and are the most important to you
everybody else doesn't [ __ ] matter
trust me you'll be a lot happier watch
this video negombo I'm talking about you
[ __ ] that's my best friend
suck a dick
a question so I decided to go ahead and
rip receive I was getting it was
goody-goody
man what the [ __ ] am I saying you want
to be the girl that all the guys when
you walk down the hall